breaking ground on land which could
yield clues about the human sacrifice of
a war which changed the face of Europe
it was in the fields around montage on
that the Battle of Waterloo was fought
200 years ago a battle which saw Britain
and her allies halt the march of
Napoleon archeologists have scoured this
land for years but never before has the
site of the field hospital where
thousands of wounded soldiers were
treated being penetrated and it's to
this spot that British veterans
themselves injured in modern-day
conflicts have come to help the search
Matt Weston lost his legs and part of
his right arm in Afghanistan he'll use
his drone and photography skills to help
catalog the work
Westby it's quite an honor really I mean
I mean the history of Europe was really
forced on this battlefield and we're
given permissions going dig it up I
think it's something that really in the
privileged few get to do and it's a it's
remarkable it always liked history but I
never really considered as you know
something I would do actually look just
just being his amazing going to meet
people I have that background it's er
pretty impressive it's the first one
found at this site Wow early finds
include a British musket ball which
could kill or cause serious injury but
ground-penetrating radar is being used
in the hope of finding medical tools and
bones from amputated limbs it's sobering
for wounded veterans of today to think
of what the troops in the Battle of
Waterloo went through but they come
because military history fascinates them
men meade suffered from PTSD after the
helicopter he was traveling in was shot
down in Afghanistan soldier is a soldier
because this 200 years ago 300 years ago
yes a mentality and from the research
I've been doing over the past year I
find the Battle of Waterloo was like the
last major romantic battle of cavalry
when an infantryman and cannon fire and
I know over time medical history
medicals advanced in time you just do
think for their mind as the fighting
intensified more and more injured were
brought here to Mount San John
it's believed as many as 6,000 men were
treated for their injuries on this site
and in the farm buildings around
Medicine was primitive with surgeons
forced to operate and amputate limbs
without anesthetic the Waterloo
uncovered project brings together
wounded and serving members of the
military with leading archaeologists as
part of a program of care and recovery
it's aimed at building confidence and
new skills and those who've seen war can
offer a special insight into the
discoveries very much so they've they've
seen war they've seen the elephant as
they say and I haven't I've always been
an archaeologist I never served and they
can bring a unique experience they've
been under fire in those locations
the early findings are already being
carefully catalogued and will help build
a picture of what those wounded at
Waterloo went through the military of
today helping to tell the stories of
those who went before them Michelle
Clifford Sky News Belgium